nick and alyssa are racing up a wall
alyssa's height on the wall is given by
the equation a is equal to one third t
plus five so it looks like sounds like
they're wall climbers of some kind where
a is alyssa's height and feet after
climbing for t seconds
nick started racing at the same time as
alyssa and is also climbing at a
constant speed his height is shown in
the following table so this is t in
seconds time in seconds this is height
and feet who started out higher alissa
or nick so to figure out their starting
position we just need to figure out what
was their height at time equal zero
that's when this whole race started
for alyssa is pretty straightforward
when time is equal to zero you have one
third times zero plus five well that's
just going to be 5 feet so alyssa's
starting position is at 5 feet when time
is equal to 0. now let's think about
nick's height at time equals 0. there's
a couple of ways that we can go about
doing this
one is it's just to back up to to kind
of go backwards on this chart so let me
show you what i'm talking about so if
this is time and this is let's say n for
nick's height because we have a for
alyssa's height so let me make a little
table here we already know that at time
six
seconds or after six seconds he's six
feet in the air or along the wall at
time eight he is seven feet in the air
or along the wall and at time 10 he has
gotten to a height of 8 feet so what's
happening here every time
every time two seconds goes by every
time two seconds goes by he increases in
one foot he increases one foot you have
another two seconds
he increases in height by one foot so
you could go backwards if we take away
two seconds to four seconds he will
decrease in height by one foot if we go
back another two seconds he will
decrease in height by another one foot
the reason why we can say this is
because we know he's climbing at a
constant speed so if we decrease by
another two seconds to our starting time
then we know that his he would have been
one foot lower so he would have been at
three feet so just like that we now know
time equals zero nick's height is three
feet in the air so alissa started out
higher than nick so this right over here
would be the correct answer
now the other way to do it is set up an
equation just like we had for alyssa and
substitute for time equals zero and the
way to do that is to recognize that
nick's height as a function of time is
also going to be a linear equation
because they're both climbing they're
both climbing at constant speeds or we
know that nick is climbing at a constant
speed so nick's height as a function of
time is going to look like nick's height
is going to be
some slope some rate of change
essentially his height per his height
per second at times time
plus his initial plus his initial
position
so how can we solve for m the slope and
his initial position
well the slope is just his rate of
change of height
so it's literally how much does his
height change per unit time
so m right over here
m is just going to be for a unit time
for change in time how much is his
height changing and his height is we use
the letter n
so we already know that when time
increases by two when time increases by
two his height increases by his height
increases by one-fourth by one foot so
we know that m is equal to one-half he
increases one-half feet per second and
you see that there because it takes him
two seconds to go one foot
so we can fill in m here so we know now
that n
n
is equal to
one half
one half
t
plus b
now to solve for b you could just
substitute one of these points all of
these points must satisfy this equation
right over here so we could use the 0.6
so if we put a 6 in here
so when time is 6
we know that n is 6. so you have 6 is
equal to 1 half times six plus b or you
get six is equal to three plus b
subtract three from both sides you get b
is equal to three so there you have it
you get nick's equation as a fun or
nick's height as a function of time nick
as a function of time is going to be
equal to one half
t
plus three
so now we have an equation just like
alyssa's and we can say well when time
is equal to zero he's at a height of
three which is lower than alyssa's
initial height